we're now ready to get into the meat of
evaluating this surface integral and we
really need to really express it in
terms of a double integral with the
parameters in the domain of the
parameters and the first thing I'm going
to do is rewrite this part right over
here using our parameters and we already
know that n our normal vector times our
surface differential is can also be
written as kind of a vector version of
our surface differential that points in
the same direction as our normal vector
and this is going to be the same thing
and we need to make sure that we get the
order on the cross product right as the
partial derivative I'm going to confirm
this in a second the partial derivative
of one of the permant with respect the
partial derivative of the
parameterization with respect to one of
the parameters crossed with the partial
derivative of the parameterization with
respect to the other parameter and then
that whole thing I'm not going to take
the absolute value because I need a
vector right over here times
differentials of the parameters D theta
D R and we can swap these two things
around depending on what will make our
eventual double integral easier but we
can't swap these two things around
because this would actually change the
direction of the vector so we need to
make sure that this is popping us out in
the right direction so let's think about
the direction that the partial with
respect to R will take us so as R
increases we're going to be moving
radially outward from the center of our
surface as our increases we just in a
different color as our increases will be
moving radially outward so this quantity
will be will be a vector that looks
something like that and then as theta
increases we'll be going roughly in that
direction roughly in that direction and
so if we take the cross product of those
two things and we could use the
right-hand rule you can imagine take
your right hand point your index finger
in the direction of that yellow vector
let me make it clear this is the orange
vector right over here take your index
finger in the direction of that yellow
vector so that's my index finger my
Shaklee drawn yellow index finger put
your middle finger in the direction of
the orange vector so my middle you bend
it and put in direction of the orange
vector and we don't care what the other
two fingers do and then your thumb will
be in the direction of the cross product
so your thumb will will point outward
like that that's my best attempt at
drawing it which is exactly the
direction we needed to point
we needed to point upward here in order
to be oriented properly with the
direction that we are actually
traversing the path so this is actually
the right order if when we did this we
got the thumb pointing into it or below
this plane then we would actually have
to swap these orders so with that out of
the way let's actually evaluate this
cross-product let's evaluate this
cross-product so the cross product of
the partial of our parameterization with
respect to our crossed with the partial
of our parameterization with respect to
theta I like to set up the matrix to
take the cross product so we'll put our
I J and K components just like that and
then first I will write the partial with
respect to R so the I component if you
take the derivative of this with respect
to R is just going to be cosine theta
cosine theta the derivative of this with
respect to R is just sine theta sine
theta and the derivative of this with
respect to R is just going to be a
negative sine theta negative sine theta
and then if we take and then we're going
to cross it with this so the derivative
of this with respect to theta is going
to be negative R sine of theta so it's
negative R sine of theta derivative our
J component with respect to theta will
be R cosine theta R cosine theta and the
derivative of K of our K component our Z
component with respect to theta is going
to be let's see negative R cosine theta
negative R negative R cosine theta is
that right yep negative derivative of
sine theta is cosine theta yep so it's
negative sine negative R cosine theta
and now we just evaluate this
determinant over here so this is going
to be equal to our I component is going
to be so ignore those row that row and
this column and we get sine times
negative R cosine theta so we're going
to get I'll just do this in a new color
so we're going to get negative R that
wasn't a new color I'll do it in purple
we will get negative R cosine theta sine
theta cosine theta sine theta minus
well this is going to be a negative
number so when you subtract a negative
number is going to be plus so it's going
to be plus R plus R cosine theta sine
theta plus R cosine theta sine theta
it's always nice when things cancel out
like this this Plus this is just zero
negative of it plus the positive so that
all cancel out to zero we don't have an
eye component now let's go to the J
component and remember we need to do our
little checkerboard pattern so it's
going to be minus J and it's going to be
ignore this column that row cosine theta
times negative R cosine theta is
negative R cosine squared theta cosine
squared theta I just multiplied those
two and then from that I'm going to
subtract I'm going to subtract this
times that and so this times that the
negative cancel I will get R sine
squared theta so this is minus let me
make sure I'm going to subtract the
product of these two the product is
positive it's going to be R sine squared
theta this is always the hard part you
can get to make a lot of careless
mistakes here and this looks like we
might be able to simplify this in a
second but I'll wait actually I'll just
distribute this negative sign just for
fun so if we distribute the negative
sign these all become positive helps
simplify things a little bit and now
let's worry about the K component K
component I will be doing in purple well
I'll do it in blue K component ignore
this row ignore this column so plus K
times cosine theta times R cosine theta
is R cosine squared theta and then from
that I'm going to subtract R sine theta
negative R sine theta times sine theta
so that's going to be negative R sine
squared theta but I'm subtracting it so
it's going to be plus R sine squared
theta and this looks like we're going to
simplify it as well and so this piece
right over here we can factor out let me
just rewrite it this can be written as R
times cosine cosine squared theta plus
sine squared theta trick basic trig
identity that just evaluates to 1 so
this is just R times J and this over
here simplifies for the exact same
reason this is R times cosine squared
theta plus R plus sine
theta sine squared theta this also is
just one so this just simplifies to R
times K and so our whole this whole
cross-product all of this business right
over here simplify to quite luckily is
equal to R times our J unit vector plus
R times our K times our K unit vector
and so now we can write our surface
integral our original surface integral
we can write as the double integral we
might want to change the order that
which we integrate but we'll give
ourselves that option a little bit later
double integral now it's going to be
over the our parameter domain or the R
theta domain so it's the double integral
of we still have the curl of F and we're
gonna have to evaluate the curl of F so
I'll just write curl curl of our vector
field F dotted with dotted with this
business dotted with this business our J
plus our K and then we have our two
parameters and we might want to switch
the order so if we maybe we could write
D theta D R and then if we do it in this
order theta goes from 0 to 2pi and r is
going from 0 to 1 but if we swap these
two then obviously we're gonna have to
swap these two as well I'll leave you
there in the next video we will evaluate
the curl of F and maybe in that video if
we have time we will get to the finish
line